bell est dominante voire encore une fois
prédatrice sa volonté de procéder au
maximum d'acquisition fait état de son
désir profond de dominer l'industrie de
cristalliser sa volonté de reconstruire
son monopole et d'éliminer ses
concurrents avec l'ajout de vie à bell
média des parts de marché de bell média
vont monter à 22 % versus tv au groupe
tva qui est à 38 pour ça au québec alors
la dominance je ne crois pas qu'elle
soit du côté de bell média
explications avec colette brin
directrice du centre d'études sur les
médias de l'université laval bonsoir
collet debré bonsoir
selon le document déposé par bell au
crtc la chaîne v perd 3 millions et demi
par année est-ce que l'avenir de la
chaîne dépend de cette transaction
je crois qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'autres options en effet en tout cas on
en a pas entendu et c'est ce qui
explique que bell est dans une position
on pourrait dire de force dans sa
soumission crtc donc elles demandent des
conditions
elle demande d'avoir un peu de champ
libre même si elle a proposé de faire
des choses intéressantes sur le plan
d'information et si certains sites
proches favorablement en faveur de
belles est-ce qu'il est exact de dire
que ça va concentrer davantage que ça va
aggraver le problème de concentration
médiatique
en fait ça dépend de quel de quel marché
on parle si on parle du marché de la
télévision au québec on parle plutôt du
maintien d'une concurrence
mais si on parle de l'industrie
multimédia qui inclut tous les secteurs
de la télécommunication c'est qu'on a de
plus en plus affaire à une économie qui
est intégrée alors et ici on parle du
marché canadien il a à ce moment là
c'est sûr que ça renforce la position de
bell cela dit lily propos de monsieur p
la douce m'apparaissent un peu excessif
mais il n'a pas entièrement tort en
disant que ça renforce la position de
belles comme joueur dominant sur le
marché canadien
on a préparé deux tableaux pour voir
l'étendue vraiment des activités des
deux entreprises quand on regarde bce
des revenus de 10,8 milliards
télédistribution internet telephony sitv
29 chaînes spécialisées sang neuf
stations de radio et serra et quand on
regarde quebecor des revenus de plus de
4 milliards possède tva des chaînes
spécialisées également et beaucoup
d'autres choses voilà que brady au
journal de montréal 24 heures qu amy
illico c'est vraiment deux grandes
entreprises qui sont très dominantes de
toute façon oui donc on comprend la
réaction de quebecor mais je pense qu'il
faut évaluer le club de berre avec ses
forces ses faiblesses
il n'y a pas d'acheteur idéal surtout
pas dans le contexte actuel la
télévision conventionnelle et
télévisions généralistes
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
intéressés à faire l'acquisition d'une
entreprise comme vie est comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une entreprise qui perd
de l'argent qui a déjà procédé à des
mises à pied et dont l'avenir était loin
des gardes pierre karl péladeau a dit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut démanteler belle
vous en pensez quoi
mais je pas certaine que le crtc va se
lancer là-dedans certainement pas dans
ce processus de demande
en fait d'octroi de licences ou de
demandes d'acquisition
si ça semble un peu étrange venant de
monsieur péladeau qui a lui-même un
empire quand même important mais en même
temps c'est vrai que la position de
belles et très dominante dans le marché
canadien ils se sont déjà des parties de
certaines de leurs acquisitions de leurs
de la propriété notamment dans le
domaine de la chaire de la télévision
par câble
mais ils sont en croissance du côté des
services numériques leur service crève
et je pense en deuxième position après
netflix au canada
donc ils sont dans une position très
très avantageuse et c'est certain qu'ils
viennent y viennent apporter un
peut-être un nouveau souffle à cette
chaîne en achats la chaîne v ils se sont
engagés aussi à investir dans
l'information comme je disais tout à
l'heure mais il ne souhaite pas que le
sertit s'en fasse une condition dix ans
donc ils veulent ils veulent avoir un
peu de champ libre tout à fait et donc
la question fondamentale demeure bel
occupe une telle position partout au
canada dans le marché anglophone dans le
marché francophone
est ce que la question de base même si
les particuliers qu'elle vienne de
pierre karl péladeau et de quebecor
demeure quand même pertinente que celle
du démantèlement de cette entreprise là
mais il faut voir qu'est ce qu'il entend
par démantèlement en fait de s'assurer
qui est peut-être un peu plus de
diversité dans l'écosystème c'est sûr
que l'importance de la place de bell et
de quebecor et d'autres joueurs comme
rogers c'est aussi le résultat des
politiques et des décisions du crtc dans
les années passent et donc ça s'est pas
fait par hasard et ça s'est pas faite en
catimini
ce sont des décisions qui ont été prises
de consolider l'industrie canadienne de
cette manière-là
hélas après seulement c'est la question
savoir si on peut remettre le dentifrice
dans le tube comme on dit et le crtc
veut avoir éventuellement évidemment il
n'y est pas rendue actuellement mais à
se pencher sur l'application des faits
des recommandations du rapport ye qui
seront retenues par le gouvernement
fédéral
donc on est
on est encore dans un chantier très
important ce qui concerne la
reconfiguration de l'écosystème
médiatique y compris numérique tout ça
est extrêmement compliqué mais ça se
réglera pas dans ce processus il est
simplement de décider si on accorde ou
non cette chanson approuve ou non cette
transaction pourquoi bell hsv à un
moment où se déploie toute une offre de
diffusion en ligne qui attire beaucoup
l'attention les netflix amazon prime
d'usiné plus notamment même crève là du
côté de bell
ben c'est une occasion d'occuper le
marché francophone le marché québécois
je pense que ça paraît très bien pour
bell c c'est presque un sauvetage en
quelque sorte ils ont choisi aussi de
soutenir je le répète parce que c'est un
peu moment trahi mon domaine mais de
soutenir l'information locale pour y
lancer à leur donne donc c'est sûr
qu'ils sont pas là pour faire seulement
une un travail sur leur image j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont ils ont l'espoir
de pouvoir bien percer ce marché là et
peut-être de faire certaines synergies
avec leurs activités déjà avec city vit
donc ça serait intéressant à surveiller
je suis pas dans le secret des
stratégies de belles mais je pense que
de manière générale à part les réactions
de quebecor qui sont compréhensibles les
réactions sont plutôt favorables à cette
transaction et donc par une diode
oui je pense que oui moi je souhaiterais
que les critères pour l'information
souhaite une condition dit sans doute
cela s'est passé cet essai sera en
mesure d'imposer sa part qu on sait ce
qu'on va voir dans les prochaines
semaines colette brin merci pour cette
analyse là c'est à vous